it's time to babble the [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
on it's Hollywood
Babylon with your hosts Kevin Smith and
Ralph
[Music]
gar
it is
Saturday it is it is is it
is it is Saturday night in Burbank man
so let's Babble the [__] on I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Ralph
Garmin
oh thank you for
remembering we were just just before we
came out we were like what is I I said
what was last time we did this did we do
it in December and he was like 6 months
ago it's been that [__] long well let
me catch you
up and uh we tried to do one back in
Jersey and Jersey said [__] you and so
we we they weren't having it yeah they
weren't oh it's I'm just kidding we love
Jersey it's called Hollywood Babylon
that's true which is why we're in
Burbank we should call Atlantic
Highlands Babylon and maybe we'd sell
more tickets might have helped man and
just before we get started to folks out
there who are listening to this after
the fact it's not that we don't want to
do it people are like where's with
Babylon when are you guys coming back
what's that what's wrong with you I'm
like it's not that we don't love doing
this but we've gotten busy and you it's
just they don't pay us enough it's
really what it comes down to it's a
we're on strike [__] it worked
for the writers it works for the actors
it's time for the podcasting strike
that's not it at all it's not the case
at all so we want all of you to pay
double from now on that's not the case
at all to subsidize our insurance not
not what I'm talking about even a little
bit um here here's a [__] little
experiment so uh this week I was lucky
enough to be asked by the good Folks at
KFI AM
640 oh this is my this is going to help
my experiment uh to sit in for Gary And
shann and they were off on Thursday and
uh Friday so they were like you want to
come in I said absolutely so I filled in
and I that I love radio so much like I
grew up listening to [__] Imus and
Howard Stern when I was a kid and I grew
up listening to Ralph sure yes you know
when I was in high school Ralph was an
adult on the radio that's right I
remember you had a field trip to the
station and I gave you a
lollipop I want to be like you one day
yeah well drink up Johnny he goes better
yet kid you'll sit next to me one day in
burp
so so um I you know going in and doing
the radio every I've been dropping hints
I've been doing my career has been 30
years long this we just passed the 30th
anniversary of Clerks debuting at
Sundays yes thank
you which means it's also the 30th
anniversary of the last time I didn't
say clerks once a
day uh but with that an somebody clapped
for that yeah uh but with that
anniversary man like uh across um uh my
my career I any time I've gone into a
radio station to Pro promote something
I'm working on I always have dropped
hint like oh I'd love to do this and
they're like yeah yeah you sure would
and I was like no like [__] seriously
take you make clerks too I'll do this
[__] like [__] I love radio and
nobody ever really takes me seriously
like oh no nobody no millionaire like
him would want a job like that and I'm
like I ain't no [__] millionaire and
I need a goddamn steady gig
so so for years I've been dropping hits
and finally somebody was like why don't
you come in and sit in and I sat in and
it was wonderful it was natural fit
they're like how'd you learn to do this
I was a listen ra my whole life plus I
was like I watched and listened to my
friend very closely when I would go into
krock all the time when I would go into
krock all the time and when Ralph was on
krock we had we we did Babylon on a
weekly basis we were able to sell out
every week because Ralph was a presence
on Los Angeles radio selling tickets so
while I was in KFI on Thursday and
Friday I was like oh my God I'm going to
[__] promote Hollywood Babylon and
see what happens cuz how many tickets
have we sold by Monday uh beginning of
the week I think we were like half sold
we about half the room sold okay so
Monday Tuesday so Thursday Friday was me
every drop going hey man me and Ralph
going to be a hollyood babyon right down
the street in Burbank with put by
putting your hands together how many
people are here because they listen to
KFI put your hands together real quick
Applause oh not that
[Applause]
many
how many you here because you heard
about it on the Ralph
[Music]
report I'm just saying I'm not saying
I'm just
saying maybe you should get a job on the
Ralph report I should I could sit in for
you God a [__] tries to spread
his wings a little bit and you're like
no you stay in your [__]
Lane that's why when you would come on
the radio with us he said I want to do
radio we'd all go no yeah don't you got
the best of both worlds right there the
and right here the uh I'm never going to
come on the radio cuz of you I was
coming on the radio Thursday and Friday
at KFI it was amazing I was having a
blast me and the four people [__]
really really had a good
time uh last since the last time I was
here I moved to the valley I remember
you said and then I moved I hold your BL
then I moved moved back to old house
yeah yeah but I was here for a red hot
minute in the valley I finally got to
live in the valley like I always dreamed
of and it was wonderful yeah apparently
you loved it so much you did that what
you sold that house within weeks and
moved back to your old place that house
yeah it's up for selling that hopefully
it closes and stuff uh but yeah that
happened what else happened I didn't
[__] none of these cats know you know
my wife shattered her hip yeah which
like she's like don't [__] tell
people that it makes me sound old and
I'm like why just cuz you're 53 she's
like don't tell people that either yikes
but uh she did freakily she fell at the
house and like landed on her hip and
shattered it [__] like I was there I
went to uh back to Jersey to interview
the Russo Brothers at SM Castle Cinema
my movie theater and when I landed I got
text from Harley going like um hey uh
have you landed and it was like bless
you it was
Co trying to stay safe here um so you
know she never text me particularly that
early in the morning and then a second
text was just like uh can you call me
when you land and I called her I was
like what's going on she's like
everyone's fine which is the sure first
sign that somebody's [__] and it's a
[__] lie by the way yes no doubt
shatter your hip you're not fine at all
totally and I was like what happened
she's like Mom shattered her hip and I
was like how the [__] did that happen
she was like she fell on the step this
step leading up to our bed is [__]
lethal we've both fallen over the course
of 20 years we've both Fallen on that
[__] stuff because the floors are
wood and [__] if you're not wearing
slippers if you're wearing socks you're
[__] and stuff so she like wants to
turn off the light she had her socks on
[__] bam and she's got like very
pronounced a very pronounced pelvis like
[__] handlebars pelvis and [__] like
that and I that to me hold on I have a
mental Vision
that okay you can go on that to me was
like that that's the hip right like I
was like oh my God she shed her [__]
hip and I thought her hip was her and
stuff I found out later on that's not
the case at all like when we were in the
doctor and the doctor put the X-ray up
he's like and here's her new titanium
hip and it wasn't it was the top of her
leg and I was like you did it wrong
that's the top of her leg and he goes no
hi I was like no that's the top of her
leg man I [__] the pelvis is right
there and he goes where the hip meets
where the where the leg top of the leg
meets pelvis that is the hip and I was
to a doctor I was like you [__] sure
and then so I learned that [__] but
anyway back to her she fell [__]
shatter her hip the two we got these two
German Shepherds man little puppy and
and the mom puppy's a year old now she's
birdie and the mom we just found out did
23 and me cuz you can't the dog's not
like a tree you can't cut it open but
count the Rings how old is this [__]
you know cuz we got her from the [__]
shelter right so we did a 23 me kind of
thing found out we thought she was like
four [__] seven and a half years old
holy crap now let's be honest could be
some dude in the office going I don't
know s and a half [__] 10 just
throwing darts at numbers on the wall
100% man but they're loyal as [__]
German Shepherds oh my God they're
[__] the're perimeter dogs all they
do is Patrol and patroling so they're
patrolling gem while she's on the floor
in agony she was like look I gave birth
to a child so I know what pain feels
like she's like this is a thousand times
where I've never felt anything like this
and stuff she's like I'm I'm on the
floor I call you know 411 she's like
luckily I have my phone on me um they
send the ambulance they send the fire
department and stuff and so they're
talking to her they're like you Mrs
Smith are you okay she's like no she's
screaming the windows are open they
could hear her on the street and on the
phone and stereo and [__] and they're
like we're we can give us the code cuz
we got one of these keyless entries like
give us a code we can enter what is that
code
again I
forget so
uh
yeah so let me go to those handlebar
pelvis that's why she didn't want to
give out the code she was like a I'm so
embarrassed to the [__] code officer
at
6969 it's like don't be embarrassed to
that that's H 269
[__] it's like
138 you're right it is it's exactly what
that
[Applause]
is since you gave up the weed you're a
lot better at math Bob just right there
it's a math lead so in any event she's
speaking to the first aid guy and the
first a guy is like uh we we'll come in
if you give us the coat she's like I
double bolted from the inside so you
can't get in he goes well you know what
the window's open fire truck's here we
got a cherry picker we're going to raise
it up to the window come in that way and
she's like whatever hurry up she's in
pain right they raise the [__] cherry
picker the first a guy climbs the top
the German Shepherds oh no are like oh
my God this is the moment we've been
waiting for like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa who you know what mugger mugger m
just went [__] crazy and the guy was
like you're on your own lady and back
down the
[__] ladder and [__] so Jennifer had
the phone she called Harley and she was
like bring Austin over break into the
house and open the front door and shut
which is very telling that [__]
Austin knows how to break into [__] even
more telling my wife knew he knew how to
break into [__] he came in broke in let
them in uh they had to cut her [__]
clothes off I was like what H were you
in did they use the jaws of life why and
she was like my entire limb was useless
it was attached to my body but
disconnected all right yeah so that she
said six uh I was going to say
veterinarians look any port in a storm
man she's in pain six of the best animal
doctors available that's what I called
in for my wife nothing but the rest they
come in and said you're a good girl
you'll be fine or scratching her ear
giving her
treats my wife is shoted her headp get
me whoever worked on
Lassie like what on the show I'm like no
on Lassie her
vet so uh they took her out man uh they
replaced her [__] hip and stuff like
that this was happened November 3rd so
like two months ago and when it happened
like for the next week you were just
like life is irrevocably changed
nothing's ever going to be the same and
[__] like that there are shower chairs
involved potty chairs involved and stuff
here we are two months later you you
wouldn't even [__] know it happened
if you're going to break or hurt
anything in this world go Osteo go
elbows H and most of our audience let's
be honest middle-aged go AAL hip elbow
knees yeah [__] your joints up yeah yeah
they have this [__] down to science they
can [__] fix you up man super easy
but she's a cyborg now man it's like
[__]
[Music]
aylon I'm like you're more machine than
man
I call her [__] skelet oh our [__]
Masters of the Universe show
drop [__] hey I think you would have
said something about that if that was
the case I've been looking at social
media yeah no I've been happy to talk
about it oh my God last time we did mass
of the universe there were some people
that were very upset uh yeah they went
after me hardcore for like years uh this
is the second part and it went up the
other day on Thursday night I guess and
uh my God I I've never been involved in
anything that has been received this
[__] well including my first film um
this is like the 180 Dee opposite
experience of what we had [__] last
time like it it's just so lovely it's
it's honestly been an emotional
experience just reading people's
reaction without having to Wade through
the disappointment or the hate or [__]
like that it's been like nothing but
love 99. [__] 9% love um Ralph is in
it as well playing playing Rio
blast um and he also plays of course as
he did last season Fisto oh
Fisto but Fisto you know spoilers based
on the events of last season of
Revelations Fisto didn't do so well in
the first season Fisto is is a ghost and
stuff so Ralph's Fisto performance is
mostly
like it's it's like the sound of pain
and [__] which being fisted is what it
sounds
like if you want to hear what Ralph
sounds like when he [__] comes that's
not at all what I base that on listen to
that first episode when scarg glow is
like you know I'm not letting them go
it's Tony Todd's great voice and [__]
and then [__] you hear like they cut
to the fist the ghostly fist of Fisto
and you
hear and then very quietly right at the
end thank
you I haven't missed this show at all
all um you you did great in the show he
also plays R bless and you have one of
my favorite lines in the entire show I
didn't write it came from Rob David and
uh he goes uh uh even uh Cowboys get the
pews as in PE
PE adorable man uh so yes that is on
Netflix right now we launched at number
six in the entire country that was
pretty sweet uh and and uh I'm very very
happy with it William Shatner joined us
this year I know it's so awesome he's
fantastic him and Mark Hamill share a
scene together acting opposite one
another so I've got [__] Captain Kirk
and Luke
Skywalker together at last
yeah so it's it's uh it's worth your
time people seem to be digging it man
it's been fun and you're in it I know
you're very you're very kind to me you
always find something for me and so I
appreciate that the uh have you heard
from anybody was anyone like oh [__]
yeah I heard a couple people who have
seen it to talk about Rio and uh they
were very complimentary
so thank you so thank you what I'm
saying you want you want to go further
than that no no no I just I just I
didn't know if we were all caught up
with you or not I don't know I just
didn't know well what kind of [__] are
they saying about my R feel like people
have reached out what do they say that
that they loved it and they enjoyed it
and they thought it was funny my my RO
they enjoyed my performance in it we'll
lead with that next time okay they liked
it people like it it's good I'm very
sens about this I know I can't
yes um it's been a while since we've
been together it's been a while thank
you good to catch up I uh I got engaged
since the last time we did this
[Music]
show yeah way to bury the lead I'm like
oh [__] Master of the Universe my
wife broke her [__] head I got some
dogs you're like I'm getting married I
was just looking for an opening pal
that's all just well that's [__]
awesome she's got all her original parts
it's just
it's consider myself
lucky no firemen are coming through the
window at her or anything one [__]
normies your man I know what are you
going to do go go cyborg dude yeah so
you know why cyborgasm
you say
so yes so we're going to get we're going
to tie the knot in the fall and so it's
going to be a good time where you going
to do it you invited uh the I'm going to
give the address out to everyone and I
hope they they'll all stop by are you
going to do it out here back East yeah
it's going to be out here yeah yeah
would you would you do us the honor of
uh officiating for
us yeah oh my God yeah I can do that I
know you can I've seen it happen right
here i' right here I've seen it happen
as a minister in the uh Universal Life
Church I uh read Kev could [__] fuse
you two people together as your one
person so we were talking about say
wouldn't it be fun if Kevin was the guy
who would uh who would make it permanent
in a harpy but let's [__] sell
tickets and invite
people not everything is a show Kev not
everything oh my God it's all [__]
content man just think about it if you
sold tickets you'd get married so like
if you would juice it all up you'd be
like I do you know yeah like hold on I'd
like to take that again I
do I do you're not directing it you're
just marrying
us cut M vs he's like cut cut can we go
again yeah I'm like hold on everybody I
just need to talk to my
actors I'm like I really don't believe
you put more truth in this real Kevin
yes her name is Jennifer where is
Jennifer I want to say where are where
are you where is she there she
is hi honey the future Mrs Ralph gin
ladies and gentlemen
I realized after I proposed it's going
to get very complicated with your
Jennifer and my Jennifer so we're going
to have to work something out it's just
too many Jennifers oh my God that's
right yeah now we both have a Jennifer
um that seems to be an age a name of an
age gone by I don't think any does
anybody name their kid Jennifer I don't
meet a lot of kids in like my kids grade
I don't meet a lot of Jennifers names
you got schol Skyler is huge
how many skylers she knows like five
skylers what do they do differentiate
with like the last letter their sky sky
yeah wow yeah could you imagine a lot of
Mia multiple Mia multiple M yeah um
could you imagine naming the kid Skylar
you're like nobody's ever going to
[__] name their kid yeah this is this
is going to make my kid special cuz I
gave her a odd name with a Y in it when
we named our kid uh Harley this was back
in 19 1999 and it was before the
character broke really really huge she
was on the uh Batman the Animated Series
of course and they brought her into the
world of the comics but she hadn't
really entered the mainstream so you
know we started telling people like he
we're naming her Harley and they were
like what do you ride and I was like no
well I guess I did ride my wife to get
her with those handlebar pelvises of
hers look out look out look out
[Laughter]
shatter so um how' you meet
him um it was uh
[__] what was I talking about I don't I
really just wanted to finish the song it
was never the pot yeah
yeah you're right yeah
you're
right used to be able to blame it now
it's just I'm stupid and
old come here come
here I really thought half the audience
came from AM
radio that's I really did I [__] you not
that's going to linger with him for a
while for tonight's show I'm not kidding
you I walked in the [__] the walk
backstage I was like guess what Ralphie
boy I sold this [__] out I'm the king
of radio
oh meanwhile [__] 198% Ralph report
audience came for you came for him or me
she came for you why thank you man there
there's there's that I'll come for you
oh my god whatever it takes watch peace
oh okay all right no don't bother me
don't bother me no no we have to shut no
we got to move on we got to move on I
was trying
to
all right you came for me too she came
for you too she
came it's like the end of Dead Poet
Society I should just go while the's
good or It's a Wonderful
[Music]
Life really is isn't
it all right let's it's a wonderful that
shit's [__] black and white and I
hate black and white movies yeah they're
the worst aren't
they let's get things kick started with
some conversation y all ready to start
the [__]
show I learned that on AM radio did you
yeah sounds very am hey work him up I'm
more FM you're more am yeah I listen to
that Ralph after dark yeah coming up
next Mr Barry White has a song for you
all about love and the ladies we lust
after say ended by saying this is pillow
talk with Ralph
G you're listening to pillow talk with
Ralph
gar I would like you to do that show on
AM radio Okay follow my show pitch me
we're going to have conversation with
folks who came here tonight from
particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions with us
here tonight it's a segment we call the
shoutouts it's a shout out with Kevin
and brown so get your [__]
[Music]
out
[Applause]
get still got it do you do that [__] at
the AM radio
station I didn't think they offered me a
gig
yeah uh Desi cuadrado from San Jose are
you here Desi hey Desi how are you from
San Jose [__] hey home sharks yeah
and the Shark Tank oh
Jesus I had no idea we had [__]
sports fans in our
audience it's awesome normally it's just
like Geeks and
stuff this is my third live show right
Desi but my first with my girlfriend
Maria who I'm bringing to the show her
first time listening to a live podcast
give it up for Maria
time Apple virgin
Maria
we just met a girl named Maria all she
knows about the show is that you talk
about Showbiz news and do funny voices
she it's all you need to know that's
really she has no idea how many dick
sucking and anal sex jokes she's going
to hear tonight have we made any yet not
just did with the microphone yeah you
did we we'll get to them yeah but that
could have been
anything she knows who you are Ralph
because I always play the Ralph report
on long drives with her but she doesn't
know who Kevin Smith is
finally yes been waiting 13 years for
this
moment what the f you don't recognize me
from the King of
Queens Desi continues she doesn't know
who Kevin is until I pull up a picture
of Jay and Silent Bob but now she
doesn't believe that's really him
because of all the weight he lost oh oh
[__] right you're unrecognizable now
fair enough so it's not that you didn't
know me you just don't know Slimmer me
yeah well pleas to meet
you could you please welcome us to The
Show by letting her know how
unbelievably amazing she is and how much
I truly adore her and how I couldn't be
where I am without her wow wow I think
you just did yeah I think we just did
but just in
case you're
unbelievable
[Applause]
I am so drunk with [__] happiness
over that Masters of the Universe
[__] acceptance I am willing to make
the worst dad jokes ever that was strong
thank you thank you Desi for coming out
thank you Maria for being here thank you
and
welcome Desi you ever dated a girl named
Lucy no that would be [__]
awesome you're [__] her like you got
some splaining to
do can't believe you did the
voice I'm doing a celebrity impression
not an ethnic stereotype excellent
[__] it's a fine line isn't it it is
and I draw it on the
rig um Richard and
Jamie only one of them is a fan of the
two of
them W shut the [__] up well Richard
wrote in but he doesn't say his wife's
name so I can't say what's what's your
knife's name Richard Michelle Michelle
okay um my wife Michelle our friend
Jamie and I Richard will be in
attendance on Saturday it's an early
birthday gift for Jamie who is an actual
42-year-old
virgin so how about you help him out and
offer him up writes Richard oh my God
I look I would do
this somebody has to be willing to
[__] we have known him since he was
13 and in all that time no
vagina well don't bring a teenager into
this well they've just known him since
he was 13 I know but you don't have to
reference that part he is drug and
alcohol free he says he's into the girls
ooh he has a job and a car ooh
oo however ladies a
vehicle for those of you who bust to
Babylon
tonight imagine riding to the next
episode in style in comfort in the
passenger seat of an actual
automobile 82
learon automobile you say yes
automobile Richard says this is the
closest he's ever been to it and he sent
in a photo I don't know if this is yeah
that's that's closest you've ever been
to oh [__] [__] yeah that's that's
Jamie with a [__] in his jie that's
Jamie he's a good-look fella who the
[__] wouldn't [__] this
guy show hands who wouldn't [__] this
guy who wouldn't [__]
him not who
would who was on the no Jamie
team well Jamie we're doing the best we
can where are you at Jamie we're the guy
with the surgical mask on all right well
I can't see why you're not getting laid
Jamie it's
just what happened that cat scratched
your
face women love the paranoid so uh um if
it doesn't work here in the room tonight
cuz it's still early know true let
people get a few drinks in them and [__]
like that but if it doesn't work tonight
is their follow-up number they could for
the home audience is there any no
personal details card
number uh Jack Aruda from Rhode Island
are you here Jack right up front the
other side of the
country the smallest state New Jersey
laughs at Rhode
Island just because of size right that's
it I'm cont contacting you from
Providence Rhode Island do you guys come
out from Rhode Island oh no I just go to
school here and from there oh okay where
do you go to school uh I go to Woodbury
University down the street Woodbury
University right on well what kind of
school is Woodbury University I'm not
familiar it has a lot of different
things Li Arts but we go for film oh
it's a film school no okay um here
bringing my friend Tony to Hollywood
Babylon to honor his 23rd birthday happy
birthday
Tony Tony you want to get laid tonight
meet
Jamie you want to spend your 23rd
birthday in such a memorable way years
from now you can tell your grandchildren
I'm my 23rd birthday I [__] a male
stranger and it was the greatest night
of my
life he never took off that
mask I don't know why Tony's Catherine
hurn all of a
sudden I remember my night with Jamie so
well Jamie you old
poop
oh [__] kids some of you may be too
young for this have no idea what I'm
talking that is some vintage On Golden
Pond humor right there 1982 year-old Kev
is like Bravo
sir I can't believe you pulled old poop
out of [__] my mind was racing for a
good Henry Fonda line I was I was
working on suck face but old poop God
damn it yeah can't go wrong with old
poop we always say here it's true every
20-year-old in the audience you know all
two of them are like what happened what
was
that can the Germans please wish Tony a
happy
birthday and some advice for getting him
into the movie business as he graduates
from Film School in five months yeah
well the German certainly can do that
Josh
nais yeah yeah Tony happy birthday to to
you Tony yeah Tony how old are you are
you
nine really you're ring for that just to
say nine AR you I start soft see that
going hard he's 23 23 23 years old I
remember that and he's at film school I
remember that as well another life
wasted do not listen to him Tony nine
wasted follow your dreams my best advice
to you you make
clerks make it three times in fact
yes you don't get it right the first
time you get two more
shots unen makes the last one really sad
yeah yeah make sure everyone's going to
laugh and then they go to theaters and
cry and say ah this is not what I signed
up
for audiences love that nothing better
than a trick them trick the audience
Tony do that with your life speaking of
trick once again M
Jamie I'll be
Tony are you both from Rhode Island are
you both from Rhode Island no just me
just you where'd you come out from I'm
from the Bay Area from the bay area
right so are they wow would over there
boo
God everything's so tribal nobody can
like some without somebody being like I
don't I don't approve I why you boo S I
just don't like things north of
me it's got to be same line as me or
lower I think is north of me uh the
Tapia family the Tapia
family holy [__] kids we're not playing
Family Feud calm down you don't win it's
Topia
family and just a second ago they were
all like
this yeah you don't win anything it's
just I'm just saying your names two
hours you've won my attention you drove
two hours from where to Hatchy where's
that that it's in the Florida swamps I
think is that where Pogo was I think so
yes right next to Oki fi where is that
really it's up near Bakersfield I think
think right is it really near
Bakersfield Bakersfield I know because
of the Clint Eastwood monkey
movies and they all took place in
Bakersfield or at least he drove to
Bakersfield that was the first time I
ever heard that expression in my life
and then when I came loves those movies
by the way [__] monkey movies best
movies on the planet you're not [__]
kidding [__] insane absolute truth I
learned how to be a man watching those
movies and how to be a monkey oddly
enough right turn Clyde not a monkey
though he's an orangutang that's right
monkeys have tals R tanks don't he's an
ape he's an ape he's a great ape he does
this
[__] isn't that awesome [__] it it's so
cute
they're cute until they're like they rip
your face off that's they're not this as
much as this that's what I learned
working with them so if they punch you
you're be like [__] you but if they pull
you that's it they're like [__]
Roadhouse like and they out yeah did you
see the [__] poster for Jake
Gyllenhaal in the new road house I have
yes you see how ripped he is and [__]
yes he's ridiculously in [__] would you
like to break that broke Back Mountain
and [__] just what a man what a man this
crazy I was looking at that poster I was
like this must be Photoshop then I saw
the trailer and I was like he got UFC
[__] tip yeah he
did I'm ready for that movie aren't you
I know some people like it's a sacrilege
to remake that I'm like it ain't going
to change the fact that the other it
looks fine that's all we need what do
you need great come on man [__] my
whole career has been about that's good
enough yeah that movie that looks good
enough man good enough to hold my
attention and [__] good enough to and
Conor McGregor's in it what yeah acting
never mind boo was acting and [__]
barely did you see the trailer it's
[__] adorable he slapped fights like
Five Guys in the beginning and he keeps
apologizing oh my God I'm so sorry I
slapped you you okay you have insurance
yeah he's adorable you know years ago
when I was working on a Green Hornet
movie I met with him we got the copia
family awaiting over here hold on kids I
know you drove two hours and [__] they
[__] shot their loads when we said
their names and now it's like this
postcoidal Silence from
you it's like you just used them and
tossed them out of
bed can we give some them some attention
at some point in the evening if you ever
want me to shut up you just have to go
right turn Clyde
and all right back to this [__]
topest yes Hortensia Carlos and
Cassandra are here tonight excellent
names give it up for the Tapas Hortensia
writes we have been wonderful parents
and of course always listen to you guys
with in the car with our children thank
you our now 18-year-old daughter
Cassandra has been has been listening
since she was
[Music]
five is that you you're the you're the
18-year-old you're the 18-year-old how
the [__] did you get in here she's 18
can you get in this place is this an 18
place oh even though they got booze here
and [__] she can't drink but she can sit
here right on get her a drink would you
no her favorite part as a child was the
Liam Nissan section because she always
shouted back how big is
it I could [__] see that that would
be fun for a
child you know for every kid that ever
enjoyed [__] door of the Explorer
where she's like where is it and you're
like it's [__] right there yeah
Swiper no swiping exactly exactly
[__] to have like two strangers being
like how big is and the whole crowd like
I could see a kid be like yeah this is
normal you know what the it is in that
segment though right you know what the
I'm just saying but maybe maybe she
never asked did you ever ask what is it
she does no
still oh kiddo well she's going to find
out tonight yeah holy
[__] we got a surprise for you yeah it's
a dick in
box that email was from Mama toia and
then yay daddy Topia also wrote in a
said this will be our daughter's first
time popping her live Babylon
Cherry it's your [__]
daughter you she's yours right I mean
it's not this isn't some like resentment
thing from like another guy or something
[__] hell it gets worse believe me
hold on it gets worse no judgment man
raise your kids your kid raise your kid
anyway you want no it's going to get
worse okay it would be awesome if Kevin
could give her a shout out as sexy
Kevin how how long have you been
18 like it's not today is it since May
May oh you're you're an old old woman
now at this point
and if you guys maybe later get a
picture with her no no I'm not I'm
uncomfortable about all of
this well why don't here run up here now
we'll take the
picture and I can't you're far too young
for me to do sexy Kev but I can do zatty
Kev if you'd
like and by zad Kev I mean uh daddy Kev
and daddy Kev even that sounds hor
this is all bad all of this is bad
father Kev sounds
worse makes every alter boy want to R
Cassandra everybody up for
Cassandra all right jump in between us
happy birthday belated happy birthday
yeah you uh
you midle get in the middle between
should we stand up perhaps yeah
also why is this taking so long no we
could do it here I want Kevin Kevin's
the King I I wouldn't say King but I
know how to make myself look thinner oh
okay well that's all that matters here
Step Up get between
us oh we got we got the projection
[Music]
in and rightly here are the
[Applause]
police there's no crime in taking a
photo that's that well met young not
what TMZ is going to
say thank you Cassandra
we'll talk to you later during the [__]
segment of our
show Dr Josh Rouse with the [__] fast
sound
effect by the way it's great to be back
with Dr Josh Rous too on the sights and
sounds bands back together again all
right I'm deeply uncomfortable by all of
that I think it's sweet that the whole
family came to that sounds bad yep I
think awesome whole family are here
together yes they've arrived together uh
Jason keman are you here Jason hi oh
they're trying to beat that family you
cannot beat the topas there's so many
there's like 19 of them they're real
loud yeah from Santa Clarita California
right on now where's
thatth it's north of us oh I don't I
don't like anything I don't like
anything north of me yeah
boo coming with a group of friends to
celebrate here tonight and forget the
woes of Our Lives except for [__] Jim
yeah [__] Jim
right [__] hate
him [__]
Jim do tell well everyone here is
battling some sort of health issue
except for Jim so [__] Jim basically is
that right break it down uh I want to
give a shout out to Heather who's about
to start chemo for breast cancer go get
him Heather go kick some ass
Heather [__] cancer to Jess whose cancer
may be back is is to Mitchell and Brian
[__] cancer go get him Jess to Mitchell
and Brian who are having all kinds of
thyroid issues oh [__] and then
there's fuam get it Mitchell and Brian
fight that thyroid [__] and then there's
[__] Jim who's just all healthy and
[__] like he's purposely doing it to in
their faces you know do they call him
[__] Jim as a like a descriptive like
Silent Bob is he [__] Jim no I think
he's just a dick called that cuz he's
always [__] he has the balls to be
healthy while everyone else is uh going
through some [__] he'll get his [__]
hate Jim hate him well Jim good for you
keep fighting Jim keep [__]
Jim as a special shout out could Arnold
Schwarzenegger sing bootylicious by
Destiny's
Child well we'll find out I guess if he
can or not I don't know
uh this is a new one I haven't
done done this song My First Ralph video
of the Year give it up
[Applause]
kids Dr jash give me a little
music I don't ready for this jelly I
don't think you're ready for this jelly
I don't think you're ready for this cuz
my body is too boot delicious for you
babe I don't think you're ready for this
jelly I don't think you're ready for
this jelly I don't think you're ready
for this cuz my body is too Bo delicious
for you babe can you handle
this can you handle
this can you handle this I don't think
you can handle
this that's enough of
[Applause]
that that excellent and lastly Dan Ruiz
where's Dan Dan's of course front center
give it for Dan he's always here thank
you he's more reliable than Ralph he is
uh Dan has created his own ongoing
segment where I sing they're coming to
take me away aha in various voices uh
coming to the show sitting next to my
buddies Jesse and Kathy where's Jesse
and make it they couldn't make
[Music]
it [__] Jim's off the hook
because Jesse and Kathy right GH uh I'm
going to be proudly wearing my wrong
reasons T-shirt oh yeah he's wearing uh
Josh ral's movie available on home video
starring Ralph
Garmin Josh where can they get it
that'll benefit you most uh probably to
be at the moment be my guest it's on
tuby yeah it's on tuby
dude we made it what's tuby I'm sorry
Freeview is you can watch movies there
periodically they hit you with a
commercial huh just buy the Blu-ray on
Amazon it's actually there you go that's
where the real coin is physical media
yeah Dan writes could you please have
Gilbert Godfrey saying they're coming to
take me away ah ah poor Gilbert we miss
him Josh when you're
ready remember when you ran away and I
got on my knees and begged you not to
leave because I go berserk well you left
me anyhow and then the days got worse
and worse and now you see I've gone
completely out of my mind and they're
coming to take me away haha they're
coming to take me away ho ho he he ha to
the funny farm where Life is Beautiful
all the time and I'll be happy to see
those nice young men in the clean white
coats they're coming to take me away
aha that
hurts I should have saved that for the
end
[Applause]
that hurts all right we also get emails
from all around the world Josh a
no G got an
email featuring Kevin's reactions that's
right Michael Chase from dreden New York
writes in longtime listener and luckily
you guys get to put on a show on my
birthday January 27th we are lucky
Michael thank
you we did it for you Mike yeah it's all
for you Micha all for you
Daman unfortunately I'm stuck in Upstate
New York so I can't make the show plus I
am I work on a daycare teacher salary so
there's no way I could make it to
Burbank that night however could Mr
David Bowie sing me a birthday song so I
can feel like I'm there I think so tell
Kevin can't wait for silent Jay and
Silent Bob 3 you're going to make
another one of those aren't you riding
right now man
um oh my God why thank you uh it is uh
yeah it's not like you know the first
two or like well the first two this
one's sad
yes who dies in this one B dies in the
third act no uh this is just straight up
comedy
Sno
I'm writing this [__] down that's not
bad um it is uh unlike the other J and
Bob movies it's not like two was a
carbon copy of one the joke was it's a
reboot and they just do the same thing
right but uh this is not like they go to
Hollywood one more time we are going to
make that movie I thought that would be
the next chain Bob movie and we're going
to make it in 10 years when Jay's
daughter Logan who is eight is 18 cuz
then she would play Harley's daughter in
the movie Harley my daughter in reboot
played Jay's daughter oh right right so
Logan when we make that movie Logan
would play Logan who is Jay's daughter
would play Jay's granddaughter right cuz
we just want to send our kids to therapy
yeah so uh I'm just wondering what if
she doesn't want to be in a movie that's
what Jordan who is is that an option
keep saying she's like you know Kevin
she may not want to do this I was like
that look she's definitely your daughter
but she definitely his daughter too oh
really and [__] if I know anything
about him that guy's just like look at
me and so she's you know she's already
ballerina I went to see her do uh what's
the Christmas show Nutcracker Nutcracker
and she had like a little solo [__]
moment where she like threw her leg up
and spun around and [__] and she's just
she trust me when it comes time you Bo
she's going to be like snooch to the
[__]
nooch just like her old man but rather
than uh wait till then I was working on
this thing and I was like this is
[__] funny I have an idea that I like
and I just kept going with it and uh
it's become this thing that like
literally it couldn't it didn't have to
be Jay and Bob you just make it any two
people right but Jay and Bob makes it
even funner and I'm a big obviously he's
my friend yes but I'm a big Jason Muse
fan I think he's an American [__]
genius and so like I I love to watch him
[__] act and I love to give him [__]
to do so uh yeah I'm I'm writing it
right now and this is this year is the
30th anniversary of J
yeah so hopefully by the end of the year
we're shooting or mid year we'll be
shooting is there uh is there things in
for for other people in the movie also
there oh you just wondering if there are
other uh other people maybe who also
maybe you like to watch them perform and
maybe there's a thing maybe there's
something in shut up
Josh it is uh you you forget [__] Jim
[__] Josh right you had no idea that
you were just auditioning for the J and
Bob movie when you were like
[Music]
oh that's the role you're going to play
Mr
[__] he's a bad guy that they fight bet
he is [__] every time he's about to
do something he's like listen here J
and he [__] himself and he's
distracted he [__] himself is that what
you just said his name is Mr [__] all
right fair enough from the guy who
brought you [__] knocker gotcha
meanwhile back to Michael Chase from in
New York David Bo singing Happy Birthday
to Michael happy to do that Josh happy
birthday to you
Micha happy birthday to you
Mel you live in DED in New York no one
knows where that town is happy birthday
to you
Michael we're so happy it's your
birthday happy birthday to you
Mel where's come
on don't touch the hair all
right happy birthday Michael Chase from
Dryden New York my camera I dropped my
camera it's still
running it's like one of those True
Crime podcasts they're like there was a
Ruckus and then we saw a [__] shadow
of a man Blair Witch
Project uh we get emails from folks who
travel around the world and they find
towns with [__] up names and we got
lazy with this one so it's called your
Town's got a [__] up
name this one comes from Bob Gordon in
San Diego California my husband and I
were traveling through Central
California oh you must hate Central
California
it's it's north of us wait what are oh
we're Southern California
CIA it was never the
pot just saying but isn't I mean even
though we're let's talk it out Kev even
though we're Southern California right
to someone else we're Northern
California if to the people at the
bottom of Southern California in San
Diego they see us as Northern California
no they don't we're all still Southern
California on AM radio
rout Bob Gordon in San Diego right my
husband and I were traveling through
Central California we found a place that
we thought we'd spend an at least an
entire afternoon enjoying we were
majorly disappointed to find out it's
nothing but a [__] a bunch of [__]
nature they found a uh they found a park
they thought was meant for them but
apparently it's got a [__] up
name
[Laughter]
yeah so promising yes the [__]
Recreation
Area isn't any Glory Hall a recreational
area though when you think about it what
else is a glory Hall and so many things
are also glory holes that's right uh we
got folks who send us stuff in all the
time that is meant for kids kids are
supposed to enjoy these things but
they're just inappropriate
toys not appropriate for girls not
appropriate for boys what the [__] is
that inappropriate
toys Shane Carlson in isua California
writes in saw this in my neighborhood
convenience store having a hard time
anyone would want to eat this he sent in
a picture of some candy that's meant for
kids it's a toilet that you stick a
plunger in and then you suck what's on
the plunger off of
it I mean yes yes yes don't try to
defend this at all I know it irritates
you but like kids like to a kid that
would be if you're a kid yeah and you
want to stick a plunger in a toilet and
then eat whatever comes off of the
plunger you need a special
school you need some
intervention even Cassandra with her
horrible upbringing I bet she never
wanted to eat what was on a plunger no
Topia has ever licked a plunger I'll
tell you that
much put that on the family crest that's
right no Topia has ever licked a plunger
lick a
plunger Jim Mauser sent this one in this
is for the Geeks and superhero fans in
the audience can we see this one
good old Wonder Woman
yes oh my Lord yeah let me tell you
something 11-year-old me would have
[__] the [__] out of
that put that back up yeah and she's
like smelling her fingers
afterwards Wonder Woman as portrayed by
Sharon Stone right
there oh my God I'm getting a heart on
now I mean that's that's yeah it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's not like dirty but
it's yeah it
is it's very dirty I mean it's how it
has to work in order for the pieces to
go like that right it's one of those uh
pieces of art that has joints that you
can position it but in order to get her
into the bag you got to make her show
her
coochie her Wonder
coochie and her legs are moving in a way
that no hip can I know because I know a
lot about dealt with that yeah
yeah this is the one I used to have sex
with this is the one I yeah that was
mine oh no no when I was a kid that was
the one that really got me going yeah
now we know why he wears his panties on
the
outside oh look at that that was a good
one I never wanted to see the bat taint
ever ring it's good stuff the batter
ring well done B ring I got it B
ring the and uh sticking with Comics uh
Ray polakowski sent this email in he
said you know kids are always people
always talking about how Comics aren't
for kids anymore yeah he sent in this
cover from an Archie comic from 1968
that was supposed to be for kids
apparently there Archie rescuing Betty
Archie did you have any trouble rescuing
me I sure did Betty I had to beat up off
three other
[Laughter]
[Applause]
guys I'm not judging but I believe I saw
that episode on the CWS Riverdale yeah I
think it's a whole different Arch po
went out for the CW yeah how about that
yeah all the heroes are
gone sorry I brought everybody down yeah
I know like that was too real yeah you
and I were both on the CW weren't you on
uh
Charmed Charmed I was on Charmed and I
was on an episode of The Flash and you
directed a [__] ton of stuff on the C I
was I wasn't going to mention that but
yeah yeah
super we were both in it on the network
a network that it exists but doesn't
exist like that anymore not really no I
brought my shirt he's wearing a flash
shirt right flash shirt right there
that's an excellent shirt king shark
king shark speaking of things that are
dead our next segment we talk about
folks in Show Business who have passed
away but have left behind careers and
and bodies of work will'll enjoy for
many years to come they're the Tinsel
Town stiffs and now another addition
[Music]
of they will be missed who died Mary
Weiss lead singer of the shangra laas
the girl group from the 1960s passed
away at the age of
75 so
is you're right leader of the leader of
the pack leader of the pack yeah what
else what what else the first hit was
remember remember walking in the sand
remember walking hand in hand you're not
that
person one person kind of half committed
to an
Applause but their biggest hit of course
leader of the
pack is she really going out with him
well there she is let's ask Betty is
that Jimmy's ring your wearing
mhm gee it must be great riding with him
is he picking you up up after school
[Music]
today by the way where' you meet him met
at
C turned around and smiled at me you get
the picture yes we see that's when I F
for leader of the
[Music]
P that's Mary there singing lead the two
girls with her are twins Marge and
maryan
ganzer all those girls out of Queens New
York they were like the bad tough girls
of the girl groups could do you could
that happen again today a concept that
simple no never I love how they're kind
of like new yorky too so where'd you
meet him is that his ring you're wearing
it's funny because it begins with a
performance like people do in dialogue
yeah they're not singing they're
literally talking having a conversation
but it's the flattest performance of all
time likey it's like it sounds like
pornography at the top of the song like
you you expect a guy [__] ring you we up
what' you do we
[__] and then all of a sudden you
hear no you
[Applause]
don't the ghost of Fisto
comes um that can't happen you don't
think uh three three girls could like
create a song that that's simple that
captures imagination nope and stand
there laconically singing it and [__] no
enthusiasm just like time gone by sadly
they were teenagers when they did that
song 15 and 16 years old those girls how
old was she she passed away she was
75 seems young right well she got
started when like I said in when she was
15 years old in the 60s when they had
their first hit could you imagine age 15
like you're people are like I [__]
love your song You're Famous everyone's
going to sing this [__] song nobody
said like in 60 years it's all over so
enjoy
it what the [__] was
[Laughter]
that just keeping it real man just it's
all fun and games but remember you are
smoking again aren't you you're smoking
again no just reminding you the clock is
ticking that's all Jesus
Christ well [__] I think about it's ma
real apparently it was a mathematical
thing if she got famous at 15 she died
at 75 I knew she had 60 years of that
life gotcha
yeah but if someone had said that to a
15-year-old girl who's singing a
song someone should have called the
authorities in 60 years it'll all be
over the next song would have been way
[__] different after that you'll be
the leader of the
Grave the band was done at' 68 by the
way so 64 to 68 was all those girls ever
had in terms of show business success
did they ever do like reunion tours and
they would travel around and sing
occasionally apparently uh well she uh a
big bucket of win right there Win w n
every once in a while on Twitter I see
somebody like will tweet big bucket of
wind yeah it's like that would not be a
compliment no big bucket of [__] wind
unless you're on AM radio then it comes
in
[Applause]
handy
feel like I got punched in the face not
at all uh speaking of Music Melanie
safka has passed away at the age of 76
she's better known by her musical name
Melanie she only went by the one name
one of the few female performers at
Woodstock in 1969 that was her
breakthrough she had a 70s hit called
candles in the rain but her biggest hit
was in 1971 when she started her own
record label and released her own song
on that brand new key here's Melanie
well I got a new oh it's the Boogie
Night song got a
new I think that we should together and
try
[Applause]
[Music]
the I was in Boogie
Nights Josh doesn't like that song
apparently turn that one down um did she
have anything else any other songs says
that um the one that I've never you
might know it if you if I if I played it
for you I can't sing it but uh Lay Laid
it all right candles in the rain no um
she also yeah she did the look what
they've done to my Song Ma look what
they've done to my song you know that
one no that was another hit of hers U
but I do know that other song that a
badass song man how old was she she was
76 how old was she when if only someone
had come to her in
1971 said 52 years it's all going to be
[__]
over you saw me trying to thread the
needle roller skating to the
Grave [__]
weirdo watching too much 2020 I guess
Norman jewison what a of a director and
produc what a care he had died at the
age of 97 this week that's a pretty good
run this guy had no particular style of
film that he directed he could do it all
you look at his body of work he was
great Agnes of God and justice for all
I'm out of order I'm sorry I can't help
myself nice um best friend Cincinnati
Kid
fist it's not a porn it's a Sylvester
Stallone film Fiddler on the Roof Jesus
Christ Superstar he directed musicals In
the Heat of the Night yeah they called
me Mr tib tibs yeah uh the hurricane
with um Denzel Moon struck Moon struck
he got Sharon Oscar direct roller ball
the Russians are coming the Russians are
coming Soldier Story Thomas Crown Affair
with Steve McQueen legendary career
Canadian Canadian man if I remember cor
thrill of it all with James Garner and
darus day I mean talk about every
different kind of film you can imagine
incredible care 97 years old when
director were directors and not [__]
aurs yeah [__] [__] '90s indie
film kids R everything ruined show
business for us yeah he's a legend he'll
be missed what a what a wonderful career
big huge bucket of win and lastly Frank
faran has passed away music producer at
the age of 82 best known in the 1980s
when he found two young men and he was
so entranced by their looks he signed
them to a record contract until he found
out they couldn't
sing and so he released their music with
them singing and
dancing so we thought Man Behind Millie
vanil know it's
true I love
you yes you know it's
true oh I love
[Music]
you we need some choreography for this
show we were halfway there I think I'm
wearing the jacket one of them was
wearing you shoulder pads and [__]
o you look very mil love you yes um you
got to admit they had a great look like
it was a good idea like oh I could sell
this and [__] yeah he's like ah you look
so beautiful I went to Pi you into
videos for music and then he heard them
singing like a li
then he hired like five people to sing
for them you think that would ever be a
big deal again if we found out some
artist that was big in videos or
something was lipsyncing to another
singer I hate to break to anyone that
thinks the gorillas are a cartoon band
well I know but like what
yeah from time to time we take a look at
things in movies and television shows
that are just uh mistakes Bloopers gaffs
mistakes call them what you will we call
[__] that should not be and now we
[Music]
not that should
not this one comes from Peter tesler he
writes that uh he
was what the
hell no no no it's an 18-year-old here
stop
it
wow so ashamed he sent this in it's from
the fourth season of the $6 million man
oh love this show this was our Marvel
back in the my God this was everything
to me when I was a kid yeah man you talk
to any 70s kid and and and let's be
honest mostly 70s boys and you talk
about like [__] $6 Million Man versus
Bigfoot oh my God that was our end game
that really was it really was uh this is
from the fourth season it's the special
Christmas episode of the $6 million man
he fights Santa Claus no no you've been
a real good boy Lee Lee Majors um no he
finds an old man who doesn't appreciate
the meaning of Christmas and he's mean
to his employees oh so he beats the [__]
out of no he doesn't battle teach him
the meaning of Christmas instead instead
of being visited by three ghost he's
visited by a man three fists from
[__] Steve Austin no Left Right
uppercut he's he's he's met by The
Bionic Man of kindness who teaches him
how to give and share the spirit of
Christmas so in this scene Colonel Steve
Austin is at the toy store and he's
buying some Christmas presents for one
of the uh employees of this old man who
doesn't appreciate Christmas see if you
can spot the [__] that should not be
good afternoon sir Merry Christmas oh
Merry Christmas to you could you wrap
these for me
sure
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
now the [__] that should not be is not
that awful mustache that Lee major is
wearing let's put that picture up if you
look over his right shoulder on the
Shelf at the toy store is a $6 Million
Man action
figure I saw that shouldn't be there no
it should not be there in their
continuity he was a secret agent he
worked for OSI exactly nobody knew his
identity so it's not like Marvel where
they could have Marvel figures and [__]
yeah huge huge eror what they what we
would nowadays call an Easter egg I
suppose you know like when they were
shooting somebody was like put his doll
in there and you know lead major like
yeah yeah [__] good take it from a
guy with a cool
mustache Oscar I think we got problems
that's pretty good thank
you we also like to take a look at
acting from around the world um not all
acting that's bad is bad sometimes it
goes all the way around it becomes
Exquisite acting to be or not to be that
is the question welcome to the world of
Exquisite acting with Ralph Garmin and
Kevin
Smith um usually we feature
English-speaking acting performances in
this segment but I thought we would
America first that's
right just cuz we don't speak other
languages that's that's right ignorance
first but I thought I would expand it a
little bit tonight uh Seth Kano sent in
this clip this is from an Indian soap
opera called sasural
simara that's my story is that your
favorite never miss it everyone in this
scene is performing some some of the
most amazing quisite acting you'll ever
see and you don't have to be able to
speak Indian what do they speak in India
H Hindi you don't have to speak Hindi to
appreciate the performances in this clip
from sasur
simar
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no
[Music]
[Applause]
shut up
[Music]
I got to tell you I was deeply
invested I was like I hope they saved
that girl cuz they all stood there when
she fell into Peril and just reacted for
like 10 minutes and [__] how do how do
you say let go of the drapery in
Hindi oh that was [__] phenomenal
that was pretty spectacular let me tell
you something that's more gripping than
anything I've ever put on
film that is the height of drama right
there I was like will she make
it till Silent Bob hangs himself on some
drapery and the next
I'm stealing that
[__] well so take a look at all the
entertainment news of the week it's the
HBO
headlines give me head give me head give
me
headines and give me
head after an exhaustive search of going
through many different Trials of new
hosts for The Daily Show They're
bringing back John
Stewart I could have told him that a
year ago really um he's coming back just
one day a week from what I understand
right yeah just he's doing Mondays and
then they rotate those throughout the
week but it' be great to have him in the
chair yeah he's this year looks like
it's going to be a wild [__]
political they said they want to keep
him through the election cycle for sure
that makes absolute sense and he's freed
up of course because his show on Apple
TV plus has since been canceled so got
some time he had a run in with the
powers that be at Apple apparently is
that right they didn't care for some of
the stories he was doing and uh he
pushed back and said I want to do the
stuff I want to talk about he revealed
that he wasn't a Mac he was in fact a PC
yeah speaking of Netflix which is a
great streaming service and we all enjoy
their work very much man if you got
Netflix uh watch Masters of the Universe
Revolution starring Ralph Garmin yes as
Dr [__] who do I play again Dr
[__] he- man's greatest enemy not
Skeletor Dr [__] as your come
man [__] writes
itself that's why they put me in charge
over that's right no writing
necessary hold on I just got a call okay
what I'm off season 3 thank
[__] uh Netflix reassured its
subscribers this week that despite the
strike delays squid Game season 2 will
Premiere this year so don't worry about
the real the real squid
not the reality show so they're going of
course they're going again why wouldn't
they yes um squid game was fantastic I
loved that first season I wonder though
if they can capture the magic again
that's my thought yeah I think so I
think they'll be inventive enough
absolutely there'll definitely be the
familiarity that makes you go this is
squid game but I bet you they're going
to be able to turn it on its head but
the premise was of course the games but
also the mystery behind who was putting
those games together and ultimately that
mystery wasn't like oh you know it was
[__] John Ham you know
it's oh that'd be awesome if it was John
that's what I was really hoping pulled
off that mask and then he's like like is
that the guy from Mad Men yes um but so
you know you keep going or maybe this
time it's a different organization I
mean they kind of set it up at the end
of the first season where the the guy
who's our hero says yeah I want to come
back and do it all over again but it
just seems like I don't know if you can
do a phenomenon like that if you can
recapture it again I guess we'll see um
I think you've asked the question that
uh every filmmaker asks when they've
made something that has really punched
through to the mainstream Yours Truly
has never done that so I couldn't tell
you for sure but it seems like the
answer whenever whatever filmmaker faces
that moment the answer is always like um
how much yeah I guess that is the
ultimate question isn't it I mean think
about it this way I know like not
everyone appreciates sequels and stuff
but you do a thing that everyone
connects with right it's like you've
you've uh gone through the effort of
doing it and one could make the argument
that you've uh become not an expert at
it but you're learned you you've kind of
mastered that one way to do with this
you obviously got something going for
you wouldn't you then isn't it useful to
put the same skills to use more than
once right rather than we did that we'll
never do it again the next thing I do
requires a different set of skills once
you learn how to do a thing shouldn't
you is it bad to do it again like I I
only it only occurred to me when I was
speaking I got a name drop right here
here so everyone back up Quenton
Tarantino oh my goodness yes thank you
picked that up for you Quenton Tarantino
was uh I was talking to him about um
Kill Bill volume one and two and I was
just blowing it up going like oh my God
I [__] love it so much and I said I
just watch him back to back again and it
was on the set of Catch and Release and
so I had time in my trailer to watch
movies and stuff so I I was after I was
done watching I was like [__] man this
is so good I wish I could talk to the
filmmaker I was like I can and so I
[__] reached out to him and I was
talking about how much I loved it
and he said this always found this
interesting he goes um I want to I was
talking about making like you know Kung
Fu movie right and he goes I want to do
it one more time and I was like what the
[__] why would you bother like you you
mastered it these two are [__]
fantastic and he goes just when I
learned how to make the movie properly
we were finished it was over he's going
and now I have like I know how to do it
and I've got the time and the effort put
in and the skills and he's like it would
feel a waste to not put those skills to
use at least one more time
and that's how I got to clerks 3 and Jay
and Silent Bob
3 and why Quenton is doing the live
action Hong Kong fuy which is coming out
soon I'm kidding that was a joke
obviously oh my God oh my God you have
to admit
though for one second we all thought
what a brilliant combination of cartoon
and real life director the the live
action dog fights with Kung Fu that's
and he cursed the whole time and [__]
that's awesome number one super [__]
guy yeah a new intro and everything
speaking of doing the same thing all
over again Universal has announced yet
another Jurassic Park
film listen to that enthusiasm yes
talking about overstaying your welcome
well I guess the idea is kids love
dinosaurs but I'm like you know the kids
that love dinosaurs they all grew up and
they're adults now yes and you know what
kids like now Tick Tock kids like only
[Applause]
fans they're bringing David cop back
he's the original writer of the first
two films David K is it K yeah I thought
it was cop um he is um he is bringing
those letters are
generally ref flipped it's K OE P that's
why you're looking at Co gotcha the way
you're looking at it a typo yeah it's
typo um yeah they're bringing him back
oh my God and then they misspell his
name here with two two P's where'd you
pull this from AI I don't I don't know
where I got this from but uh the
important part is They're bringing back
a series that is dead that's all that
matter they they won't stop with this
Jurassic no no they won't they stopped
once and then they tried it again it
made over a billion bucks and they're
like [__] they're back and they're
never going away they promis this time
they've got
lightsabers it's a new Jurassic era
where uh no one connected to the other
films the Jurassic World Series or the
Jurassic Park series will be back back
for these so none of the original legacy
cast and then none It's a Brand New
Start no Chris proud either it's going
to be just uh Lady Gaga
and and
Drake you should be in charge of a
studio man that movie make a lot of
money like that cuz you know what else
kids love Drake and Lady G that's true
they too the George Carlin estate is
suing the makers of that AI comedy
special that was awful yeah I and I'm
glad this seemed like like AI thing and
they never asked like when they
announced it I thought like oh maybe
this is some sort of experimental thing
involving the estate but I have no
problem with an estate that wants to
make a deal for some company they want
to reproduce Whitney Houston's estate
did that when she was a uh you know
[__] 3D hologram right and that went
very
well it didn't um but they were in on at
her estate yes George carin's Estate
I've saw a tweet from Kelly Carlin and
she was like I I didn't ask for this
nobody asked me to do this no and if you
really want to you know interact with my
father's work there are a number it's
out there of specials that he did yeah
and apparently that's what they're suing
about is this AI claims they took all of
George Carlin's original work and stuck
it into a program to get this weak
reproduction of what they put out as
this comedy special was called George
Carlin I'm glad I'm dead and um it was
awful but the legal point is you took
copyrighted material and you stole it
and you put it into a program and that's
against the law plus you appropriated
his likeness because they're doing an
impression of him as well yeah that's
all of this s seemed like an bad ill
begotten idea and now it looks like it's
proceeding to court because of it but
this is going to be a landmark case
because this will set up precedent for
other people who get their material or
their trademark or their images stolen
by people who want to use them with AI
um and that's like they they're can
approximated because just like with uh
who is it like U uh James Earl Jones
right uh the voice of James Earl Jones
everything he ever said as Darth Vader
has been put into like Ai and now they
can make Darth Vader say anything they
want right like I pooped [__] like that
nobody can say [__] I can't wait for
that one but um don't go in
there so one light a
match but he sold his voice and rights
he was involved but this is just like oh
I like Carlin let's do this and that's
yeah yeah unless you got the permission
of the family which they were never
going to give Billy Joel has announced
he is going to release new pop music for
the first time in basically three
decades he's got a new song coming out
Billy Joel's so [__] successful that
he hasn't had a new song in 17 years and
it doesn't matter he's richer than ever
now just on his catalog his catalog he
could just sing and he's had this record
breaking run at Madison Square Garden
yep for the last two five years couple
years at least he's coming up to his
150th show I think and that's going to
be the end I think he's wrapping it up
how old is he he is uh 74 74 years old
Jen and I went to see him at sofa here
in Cal in Southern California and it was
an amazing show he's still a great
performer it was terrific but he's never
released he did a he did a final album
and the last song on that album was
called famous last words and he said
that's it for pop music I'm not write
anything new but I will keep playing my
hits and for some reason he is coming
out of retirement and releasing a new
song on the 1st of February and then
he's going to be performing it on the
Grammys so nobody's heard it yet no but
there is a teaser can we sh a little
teaser
Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the greatest song I've ever
heard well it looks like he learned to
play the piano for it yes he's
finally got some Talent um I look
forward to hearing that he's a old
school favorite man I mean even though
he's uh what is he he's Long Island
right Long Island yeah he was still very
Jersey claimed him as one of their own
Philly did too when I was growing up he
was a huge influence do you know
somebody told me recently the Philly
claim Springsteen as well we were one of
the big markets that he first broke in
yes oh sorry
Jersey I'm with that guy over there I
don't like anything [__] south of me
he he blew up in Philadelphia was one of
the major radio markets that first
started playing didn't realize that like
that that was one of the markets that
broke through famous story about the '
70s where one of our local DJs who broke
a lot of these guys how was having a
late night Diner bull session with
Springstein Billy Joel and Barry Manalo
the four of them were sitting at the
same table cuz they were all three bees
the three piece Bruce Barry Billy Billy
yes yes took you a second it did they're
all sitting there after they had all
performed locally in Philadelphia and
this DJ gathered them together cuz they
were both all sort of baby artists who
were just trying to break through and
they put a bet on who was going to be
famous who was going to break out and
make it and everybody universally voted
for Barry
Manalo but they all did but they all did
what are the odds right that is crazy
yeah my mom loved Barry Manalo well sure
still does my mom's still around she
still loves Barry Manalo she got uh like
Alexa like one of those Alexa things but
this is as like a bass and a screen and
it moves when you talk so holy [__] it
looks like Wall-E
so if my mom is like Alexa this [__]
thing comes to life and turns to face
her so you know she'll be like Al that's
great very much so so like I'll be like
you know she'll be like Alexa play Barry
Manalo and then Alexa like looks at her
and says here's the best of Barry Manalo
and Barry Manalo starts playing then
you'll be sitting there you know
suddenly Barry Manalo is this subject
and [__] she'll be like remember how
we listen to be I said yeah M we grew up
listening to Bar in Manalo I said I
wonder how old he is and my mom goes
hold on
Alexa the [__] screen turns back to
her how old is Barry Manalo Barry Manalo
is 11
d00 and my mom invariably is just like
oh but he looks good for his age I was
like Ma you might have missed the boat
with old Barry Balo yeah I don't know if
he'd be interested at this stage Barry
does very specific taste yes he does
she's like oh tiger I know Barry man
looks like my Aunt
now I had an elderly Aunt who looks just
like Barry mandalo does now can she sing
like him no sadly that's why we have no
money in my family do you have uh are
you a Barry I mean I'm not going to say
are you a Barry Manalo fan but like we
grew up and he was popular so part of
the popular music scene I um you have a
favorite bar there were a few songs of
his that I enjoyed but overall I was not
uh not a fan uh Copa Cabana that was one
of the ones it's a [__] Banger man
her name was Lola I'm familiar with was
a show familiar with the song used to
liquor nipple
here there nope you don't remember that
it was a sexy song
no you know the few songs of his I liked
were ready to take a chance again from
Play I like that song ready to take the
chance again once again I'm familiar
with how the song goes what else you got
um week in New Eng weekend in New
England was a big song for me when I was
growing up I don't know that's F time in
the city Takes Me Away you know know
that one keep
going is that when will arise me when
will I touch you when will strong he
knows the
words and when will I hold
you
again
you and I could totally [__] 78-year-old
women oh totally yes espe their name
just like Barry Mandy myy oh my god
manzy oh Mandy you came and I came and I
took
off not sure if those are the lyrics you
came and I came and you cleaned up oh
come on cuz I had to get going oh man
did you come I didn't check I gotta go
by all right
okay speaking of musicians I'm not a fan
of Justin Bieber's in the
news
Bieber
[__] you want to know why I'll tell
you why CU you're a
little wonder if Cassandra sang along
with that one as a child
too did she just put her thumb up yeah
I could see a kid wanting to sing along
no the whole when you hear the whole
audience do it the kid doesn't even have
to understand to be like yeah you're
kind uh Justin Bieber is in the news
rarely these days CU he doesn't do
anything anymore but he let a film
that's at the sundan film festival use
one of his famous songs in their
soundtrack One Less Lonely Girl shows up
in an indie film called my old ass which
debuted
past Saturday at the Sundance Film
Festival um and he also he also was uh
it's an interesting concept my old ass
is about a teenager who takes mushrooms
and then runs into her older self and
the older self tries to keep her from
making the mistakes she made when she
was a teenager that's cool um the reason
he's in the news however cuz he was at
dinner this weekend in Santa Monica and
he went by himself and everyone's saying
his marriage may be in trouble because
he wasn't without his wife just cuz he
went to dinner by himself that and
because he was wearing this outfit I
think a lot of people were talking too
which may explain why he was by himself
when I think about it that that looks
like 70s crocheting it does yes and he's
just as happy as he always is he's just
living his best life isn't he I mean do
you think he ever wishes that none of
the fame stuff happened do you think
like when it happened somebody was like
in 50 years yeah I don't think that's
happened
let's take a look at some of the geek
news Josh Kevin Kevin Kev
news speaking of the CW the network that
the arrow verse built yeah em Emily bet
Rickards and Steven Amel are co-starring
in a new project uh he played of course
Arrow she played Felicity Felicity smoke
yeah they're back together again as
Calamity Jane and Wild Bill H
in what in a film called Calamity Jane
and Wild Bill
Hickok they didn't really bury the lead
they no they didn't no apparently they
were I guess I don't know if this is
historically accurate but they had a
romantic relationship and when Wild Bill
Hickock is killed apparently Calamity
Jane goes on a vengeful uh quest for
justice is that right yeah sounds pretty
cool sounds pretty good uh the film will
be available on tuby which once again I
don't know what that is
it's the [__] home of of [__] of
wrong reasons there you go well played
yes ah this is I believe that's their
slogan now the the home up wrong reasons
watch it for all the wrong
reasons this is fascinating to me at the
Sundance Film Festival the new
documentary dvo debuted about the band
Diva I would totally watch the [__] out
of that apparently it's great really and
while doing press for it um Mark
mother's ball yeah yeah was talking
about a very special concert event that
he and dvo were playing when Robert
zamus and Steven Spielberg were in the
audience and came up to him after the
show and they had a very interesting
conversation he tells it better than I
so here's the clip and they walk up to
me and they say hey we want to talk to
you about something and we have a film
we're working on and we wanted to talk
you about working on it with us and I'm
like oh that's sounds great and I just
remember for like two weeks I kept
thinking they're going to hire me to
score their film and so I went into this
meeting and they said well we loved you
on stage we love the way your band looks
and we love the way you guys are doing
we want you to be a sort of a crazy mad
scientist in this film we're doing and I
go what do you mean and they go well
there's an act there's a there's a part
in the film of a of a guy who who's you
know runs around in a lab coat and he
has a a card that he turns into it goes
through time and everything we want you
to play that part and I
go I I don't want to act in a movie and
they go well you you act on stage you do
great I go well we make that stuff up
ourselves I mean I I don't do what other
people you know I've never had people
ask me to I don't want to do that and I
just remember leaving amling and going
they didn't ask me to score the film I
cannot believe it I thought that's what
I was going to happen here so you could
have been Doc Brown in a movie that has
made Untold millions of dollars well
there you
go would have been a very different film
with Mark mothers ball W that's crazy
man isn't that crazy could have been
right um that's i' never heard that
before I hadn't either when I heard it
this week I said that's amazing they
should have switched they should have
had uh um Christopher Lloyd be the lead
singer of dvo and had they could have
just for a week or so they could have
just swapped whip it whip it
good we that man we are Doo
excellent Dune 2's coming out anybody
care apparently people do care I like
the first one a lot yeah I woke up about
halfway through and I said n this is
pretty
good uh it's well made I love him as a
director Denny V you great director
right Dune 2 coming out of course
they're uh taking advantage of that with
the exclusive popcorn buckets have you
seen this this is a big thing now with
big wide releases they have special
popcorn bucket for the first couple
months it's in a theater just to give
the fans something to be excited about
some people less than excited about the
Dune popcorn bucket I don't know if
you've seen it or not can we take a look
oh my God everyone's going to try to
[__] it that's what everyone's saying
look at it it's it looks like a
sphincter it's more of a Fleshlight than
it is a popcorn bucket it's got but you
know generally you bring those things
home you never use them again that one
multiple uses and it's easy to wash so
it's got so much going for it I'll take
a shot all
right wow well before we say good night
folks we have one last bit of business
to take care of Cassandra you'll be very
happy to
know we're going to be talking about
Liam niss who apparently has an enormous
penis I don't know if you're familiar
with this or not your parents have
probably told you all about it um one of
the biggest [__] in Hollywood and every
week you guys send it what it's true so
funny the way you say it one of the
biggest [__] in Hollywood he has one of
the bigest but he's not one he's very
very loved by people people seem to like
him yes but you fol people seem to love
his [__] they Doo and they send in facts
about it each and every week here to the
Ralph report it's time to take a look at
Liam n's
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] penis that's
right by the way have we've been doing
this for over a decade this show very
much more than a decade yeah um which
means we've been doing years 13 years so
we've been doing this bit for 13 years I
don't know if we started with this bit
but came on pretty early in the uh
creation of the show yeah sooner or
later we're going to get him to come do
this with
us I wouldn't say
no you know how we're going to do that
the power of AM radio oh sure
yeah Liam's going to be driving in his
Lambo just listening to AM radio talk
radio 6:40 y I really should go on and
do that
show Liam n's [__] is so big how big is
it Donald Trump has to paid $83
[Laughter]
million yeah it's not the only one Lam n
SC is so big how big is it it took
Phineas fog 80 days to travel around it
in a hot air balloon that's a very esic
deep cut yes Liam n's [__] is so big how
big
bill bellich has just been hired to
coach
it finally got a job he finally did Liam
n's [__] is so big how big is it Liam
used it to cut through doors in The
Phantom
Menace I think we have a picture of that
don't we don't we have that
[Applause]
thing yeah he did
that and lastly Liam n's [__] is so big
how big is it Taylor Swift is in the
audience every time he unzips his
fly ladies and gentlemen of Burbank if
you had a good time is
a we can't thank you enough for being
here with us tonight thank you so much
give it up for our man Josh Rous Dr Josh
Rous on the Wheels of
Steel and there is no show without the
guy standing next to my Lefty give it up
for [__] Ralph [__] Garmin kids
let's hear from my buddy and babble
brother Mr Kevin
Smith and that is Hollywood Babylon for
this week up Kevin Smith I'm Ralph gar
Babble the [__] off good night
Hollywood give it up for Ralph Gman and
Kevin
[Applause]
Smith this is the m greetings everybody
and welcome to the AKA ask anything
every Saga has a 10year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with Jay and S Bob get old I'm
Kevin Smith
k